The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HONG LIU: OK, let's start.
So first let me just
remind you what we
did at the end of last lecture.
So we see that the large N
expansion of gauge theory
have essentially exactly the
same mathematical structure
with, say, the mathematics of
the [? N string ?] scattering.
And so here the observable
is a correlation function
of gauging
[? invariant ?] operators.
And then these have a large
N expansion as follows.
And on this side you have
just an N string scattering
amplitude.
Just imagine you have some
kind of scattering of strings,
with total number of N strings.
And then this also
have expansion
in terms of the string
counting in this form.
So now, if we identify--
so if we can identify the g
string as 1/N. So if we
identify g string with 1/N,
then these two are essentially
the same kind of expansion, OK?
And you also can identify
these external strings,
string states,
within the large N
theory which we called
the glueball states
for single-trace operators.
And then each case is
corresponding to [? sum ?]
over the topology.
It's an expansion [? in ?]
terms of the topology.
So here is the topology
of the worldsheet string.
And here is the topology
of Feynman diagrams.
Here is the topology of
the Feynman diagrams.
So still at this
stage, it's just
like a mathematical
correspondence.
We're looking at two
completely different things.
But probably there's no--
yeah, no obvious connection
between these two objects
we are discussing.
Yeah, we just have a precise
mathematical structure.
But one can actually argue that,
actually, they also describe
the same physical structure
once you realize that when
you sum over all possible
Feynman diagrams.
So once you realize that
each Feynman diagram, say,
of genus-h can be
considered as a partition,
or in other words,
triangulization
over genus-h surfaces,
[? 2D ?] surfaces.
OK.
So if you write more
explicitly this fh,
so if we write explicitly this
fh, then this fh, this fnh,
then will be
corresponding to your sum
of all Feynman
diagrams of genus-h.
Suppose G is the expression
for each Feynman diagram.
Say for each diagram.
And then I can
just rewrite this.
In some sense, I [? accept ?]
all possible triangulation
of [? a genus-g ?] surface.
Say there will be some
weight G. And summing over
all possible
triangulations of a surface
is essentially-- so
this is essentially
the same as this sum over
all possible surfaces.
So this is a discrete version.
So sum all possible
triangulations
of some genus-g
surfaces, or translations
of genus-g surfaces.
Then they can be considered
as a discrete version of sum
over all possible surfaces, OK?
AUDIENCE: So you're saying
it's like a sum over
[? syntheses, ?] like
a simple [? x? ?]
HONG LIU: Exactly.
Exactly.
Yeah, because, say, imagine
when you sum over surfaces,
so you sum over all
possible metric.
You can put [INAUDIBLE].
And that's the
same way as you sum
over different discretizations
of that surface
once you have defined the
unit for that discretization.
So if we can identify--
so for now record this Fh.
So this Fh, this Fnh
is the path integral
over all genus-h surfaces
with some string action,
weighted by some string action.
So if we can, say,
identify this G
with some string action-- the
exponential of some string
action.
Then we would
have-- then one can
conclude that large N gauge
theory is just a string
theory, OK?
That large N gauge theory
is just a string theory,
if you can do that.
In particular, the
large N limits--
so large N limit here,
as we discussed before,
can considered as a classical
theory of glueballs.
Or a classical theory of
the single-trace operators.
So this would be matched to
the classical string theory.
So as we mentioned last time,
so I was mentioning before,
this expression-- so just
as in the as we discussed
[INAUDIBLE], the
[? expansion ?] in g
string the same as
expansion in the topology.
And the expansion
in the topology
can also be considered
as the expansion
of the groups of a string.
Because whenever you add
a hole to the genus--
when you add the genus, and you
actually add the string hole,
you add the string loop diagram.
So in this sense, you can
[? integrate ?] all these
higher order corrections,
as the quantum
correction to this
classical string behavior.
So this is just a tree-level
amplitude for string.
And this [? goes ?]
one into the loops.
Whenever you add this
thing, you add the loop.
OK.
Is this clear?
Now, remember what we
discussed for the torus.
If you've got a torus,
then correspondingly
you have a string split
and joined together.
And this split and join
process you can also
consider as a string loop,
a single string going
around a loop, [? just like ?]
in the particle case, OK?
In the standard
field theory case.
And so the large N limit, which
is the leading order term here,
would map to a leading order
in the string scattering.
And the leading order in the
string scattering-- they only
consider tree-level
[? skin ?] scatterings,
and then corresponding to
classical string theory.
And also the
single-trace operator
here can be mapped
to the string states.
Yeah, can be mapped
But this is only-- this
is a very nice picture.
But for many years,
this was just a dream.
And because this guy looks
very different from this guy,
but this is
difficult. So this has
some [? identification is ?]
difficult for the following
reasons.
So first, so this G just--
say your Feynman diagrams,
amplitude for particular
Feynman diagram.
So G is typically
expressed as product
of field theory propagators.
So imagine how you evaluate
the Feynman diagram.
The Feynman diagram,
essentially,
is just a product of
the [? propagators. ?]
And then you integrate
it [INAUDIBLE]
integrated over spacetime.
So they just take the
Yang-Mills theory.
And if you look at the
expression for this diagram,
of course, it looks nothing.
So they look nothing like-- OK.
So let me make a few
comments about this thing.
Because if you want to match,
say if I gave you a Yang-Mills
theory, so I gave you a QCD,
then you can write down-- then
you can go to large N. You
can write down expressions
for the common diagrams.
But if you say, I
want to write it
as a string theory, the
first thing you have to say,
what string theory do
you want to compare?
So first you have
to ask yourself
what string action do
you want to compare.
So the string action, as
we discussed last time,
this describes the
embedding of the worldsheet
into some spacetime.
OK, so this is worldsheet
into a spacetime.
So this is also sometimes
called the target space.
So this is a spacetime.
This string moves.
And the mathematical
of this is just the--
this is encoded in this
mapping X mu sigma tau.
OK, X mu is the
coordinate for M.
And then sigma tau
is the coordinate
as you parameterize
your worldsheet.
So in order to write
down action, of course,
you have to choice
of space manifold.
You have to choose
your spacetime.
And also you have to--
when you fix the spacetime,
you don't have a choice.
And sometimes the way to write
down such kind of embedding
is not unique.
The action for such
[? finding ?] is unique,
so you only need to choose
what action you include.
And also often, in
addition to this embedding,
sometimes you can have
additional internal degrees
freedom.
living on worldsheet.
For example, you can
have some fermions.
Say if you have a
superstring, then
you can have some
additional fermions
are living on the worldsheet,
in addition to this embedding.
So in other words, the choice
of this guy in some sense
is infinite.
And without any
clue-- so you need
some clue to know what to
compare the gauge theory to.
And otherwise,
even if this works,
you're searching for some
needle in the big ocean.
And then there's another
very important reason
why this is difficult, is
that this string theory
is formulated in a continuum.
It's formulated in a continuum.
And these Feynman
diagrams, even if they're
corresponding to some
kind of string theory,
they correspond into a
discrete version of that.
So at best, it's a
discrete version.
So we expect such a
geometric picture for G,
for these Feynman
diagrams, to emerge only
at strong couplings.
OK?
Emerge only at strong couplings
for the following reason.
So if you look at
the Feynman diagram--
so the simplest Feynman
diagram we draw before,
say for example
just this diagram.
And if you draw
it on the sphere,
it separated the sphere
into three parts, OK?
So this [? discretizes ?]
a sphere into three parts.
And essentially, just as
the sphere just becomes
three points, because
each particle is wanting
to-- when you're trying
to [INAUDIBLE] each part,
you approximate it by one point.
So essentially, in
this diagram, you
approximate the whole sphere
essentially by three points.
OK.
And of course, it's hard to
see your [? magic ?] picture
from here.
And your [? magic picture ?]
you expect to emerge,
but your Feynman diagrams
become very complicated.
For example, if you have
this kind of diagram,
because of the
four-point vertex.
In principle, you can
have all these diagrams.
And then this
[INAUDIBLE] [? wanting ?]
to discretize-- yes, I
suppose this is on the torus.
Suppose you have
a-- for example,
this could be a Feynman
diagram on the torus, OK?
For the vacuum [? energy. ?]
And now this is next some
kind of proper discretization.
And this will go to
a continuum limit,
say when the number of
these box go to infinity.
When the number of
box go to infinity,
then you need a
number of propagators,
and the number of vertices
goes to infinity, OK?
So in order for
continuum, a picture
to emerge, so you
want those complicated
diagrams-- it's not your number
of vertices or large number
of propagators that dominate.
And for those things
that dominate,
then you need the
strong coupling.
Because with this coupling, this
is the leading order diagram.
And there's no
geometry from here, OK?
So in order to
have the geometry,
you want the diagram are
very, very complicated,
so that they
really-- [INAUDIBLE]
a triangulation of a surface.
A weak coupled diagram with
small number of lines will
cause [? one ?] [? and two ?]
are very close triangulization
of a surface.
So we expect this only appears
in strong couplings, OK?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: By the cases like
we have to sum over all the
[INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Yeah, sum over
the [INAUDIBLE] diagram.
AUDIENCE: Including
those simple ones.
HONG LIU: Including
So that's why you
want to-- so if you're
in a weak coupling,
then the simple ones--
so we sum all those diagrams.
And each diagram you can
associate with a coupling
power.
So at weak coupling, then
the lowest order term
would just dominate.
And the lowest order term
have a very simple diagrams.
And then that's because
[? one ?] and [? two ?] are
very crude triangulization
over the surface.
But if you have a strong
coupling-- in particular,
if you have an infinite
coupling-- the diagrams,
the infinite number of
vertices will dominate.
And then that's because
[? one ?] and [? two ?] have
very fine triangulization
over the surface.
And then that can go
to the [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
interaction a coupling constant
has been [? dragging ?]
out from--
HONG LIU: No.
That's just N dragged out.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
HONG LIU: No, there's what
we call this [INAUDIBLE]
still remaining.
By coupling, it's only [? N. ?]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HONG LIU: No, no, this isn't
to [? hold ?] coupling.
In coupling we mean
that [INAUDIBLE].
So example we talk about,
[? because one ?] [? and two ?]
[INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, and then we
make more precise.
So in the [? toy ?] example
we talked about before.
So previously we talked
about this example,
N divided by lambda, trace,
say 1/2 partial phi squared,
plus 1/4 phi to the power 4.
And strong coupling
means the lambda large.
Because of the N I've
already factored out,
so you're coupling just lambda.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
HONG LIU: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So in
these [INAUDIBLE]
the propagator in that
version would become
the spacetime integration?
HONG LIU: Hm?
AUDIENCE: I was
just wondering how
the propagator can
[? agree, ?] can match
to the spacetime [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Yeah, yeah.
So the propogator--
yeah, propagator you
do in the standard way.
You just write down
your propagator,
and then you try
to repackage that.
As the question, you
said, whatever your rule,
Feynman rule is we just
do that Feynman rule.
And you write down
this expression.
It's something very complicated.
And then you say, can I find
some geometric interpretation
of that?
Yeah, what I'm saying is that
doing from this perspective
is very hard because you don't
know what thing to compare.
And further, in the
second, you expect
that your [INAUDIBLE]
would emerge only
in those very
complicated diagrams.
And those complicated diagrams
we don't know how to deal with.
Because they only emerge in
the strong coupling limit,
but in the strong
coupling limit,
we don't know how
to deal with that.
And so that's why
it's also difficult.
But [? nevertheless, ?] for
some very simple theories, say,
if you don't consider
the Yang-Mills theory,
you don't consider
the gauge theory.
But suppose you do consider
some matrix integrals.
Say, for very simple systems,
like a matrix integral.
So this structure emphasizes--
this structure only
have to do with you
have a matrices, OK?
And then you can have
matrix-valued fields [? or ?]
this structure will emerge.
Or you only have
a matrix integral.
So there no field at all,
just have a matrix integral.
That same structure
will also emerge.
For example.
I can consider theory--
have a theory like this.
Something like this.
And have a theory like this, OK?
And M is just some
[INAUDIBLE] matrices.
So this is just integral.
And the same structure
will emerge, also,
in this series when we
do large N expansion.
So that structure have nothing
to do-- yeah, you can do it.
So matrix integral is much
simpler than [INAUDIBLE] field
theory because you have
much less degrees freedom.
So for simple systems like, say,
your matrix integral or matrix
quantum mechanics,
actually, you can
guess the corresponding
string theory.
Because also the string
theory in that case
is also very simple.
You can guess where is
simple string theory.
But it's not possible
for field theory.
It's not possible
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So what do you mean
by matrix quantum mechanics?
Like that, OK.
HONG LIU: So this is
a matrix integral.
And I can make it a little
bit more complicated.
So I make this M to
depend on t, and then this
become a matrix
quantum mechanics.
Say trace M dot squared
plus M squared plus M4.
Then this become a
matrix quantum mechanics,
because it only have time.
And then I can make
it more complicated.
I can make M be t, x.
Then this becomes one plus
one dimension of field theory.
AUDIENCE: So in what context is
this matrix quantum mechanics
[? conflicted? ?]
HONG LIU: Just at
some [? toy ?] model.
I just say, and this is a
very difficult question.
You said, I don't know how
to deal with field theories.
Then this [? part of it's ?]
a simple system.
And then just try to
use this philosophy,
can see whether it can
do it for simple system.
And then you can show that
this philosophy actually
works if you do a matrix
integral or matrix quantum
mechanics.
Simple enough, matrix integral
and matrix quantum mechanics.
OK.
And if you want
references, I can give you
references regarding these.
There's a huge, huge
amount of works, thousands
of papers, written on this
subject in the late '80s
and early '90s.
So those [? toy ?] examples
just to show actually
this philosophy works.
I just showed this
philosophy works, OK?
But it's not possible if we
want to go to higher dimensions.
Actually, there's one paper--
let me just write it here.
So this one paper
explains the philosophy.
So here I did not
gave you many details,
say, how you write this G
down, how you in principle
can match with this thing.
With [? another ?]
maybe [INAUDIBLE]
you can make this discussion
a little bit more explicit,
but I don't have time.
But if you want, you can
take a look at this paper.
So this paper discusses the
story for the matrix quantum
mechanics.
But in the section 2
of this paper-- so this
is a paper by Klebanov.
So in the section
2 of this paper,
it explains this mapping
of Feynman diagrams
to the string action.
And this discretization
picture give you
a nice summary of that
philosophy with more details
than I have given to you.
So you can take a look at that.
And this paper also has
some other references
if you want to
take a look at it.
OK.
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, but who
was the first to realize
this connection
between the surfaces
in topology of Feynman diagrams?
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Who first
realized this relation
between topology and--
HONG LIU: So of
course, already when
't Hooft invented this
large N expansion,
he already noticed that this
is similar to string theory.
So he already commented on that.
And he already
commented on that.
And for many years people
did not make progress.
For many years, people
But in the late '80s--
in the mid to late '80s,
people started thinking
about the question
from this perspective,
not from that perspective.
So they started to
think about the order
from this perspective.
Because just typical string
theory are hard to solve,
et cetera.
So people think,
maybe we can actually
understand or generalize our
understanding of string theory
by discretize the worldsheets.
And then they just
integrate over
all possible
triangulization, et cetera.
And then they realized
that that thing actually
is like something
over Feynman diagrams.
And then for the very
simple situations,
say like if you have only
a matrix integral, actually
you can make the
connection explicit.
So that was in the late '80s.
So people like [? McDowell ?]
or [? Kazakov ?] et cetera that
were trying to explore that.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: I'm having
trouble seeing
how the sum over all
triangulations [INAUDIBLE] each
surfaces.
How does that correspond to
the discrete version of summing
over all [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: Right.
AUDIENCE: That's the discrete
sum over all possible
[? genus-h, ?] right?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
I think this is the example.
Yeah, let's consider torus.
So a torus is a box with
this identified with this,
and this identified with that.
OK.
And let me first just draw
the simplest partition here.
Just draw like that.
Yeah.
Let me just look at
these two things.
So suppose I give each box--
so if I specify each box,
say, give a unit area.
OK?
And I do this one,
I do that one,
or I do some other
ways to triangulize it.
Then because [? one and two ?]
give a different symmetric
to the surface.
And then because
[? one and two ?]
integrate over all possible
metric on this surface.
And they integrate over
all possible metric
on this surface, you can
integrate [INAUDIBLE]
all possible surfaces.
AUDIENCE: In the case of
the strings for example,
[? we put some ?]
over the torus here
and the torus and
the torus there.
HONG LIU: No, no.
You only sum over
a single torus.
Now, what do you mean by summing
over torus here, torus there?
AUDIENCE: I thought like
in the path integral,
in the case of the
string theory--
HONG LIU: No, you're only
summing over a single torus.
You're only summing
over a single surface,
but all possible ways to
write-- all possible ways
to draw that surface.
So what you said about
summing torus here,
summing torus there, because
[INAUDIBLE] what we call
the disconnected amplitudes.
And then you don't need to
consider them in physically
disconnected amplitude.
You can just
[? exponentiate ?] what
we call by connected amplitude.
And you don't need to
do that separately.
So once you know how
to do a single one,
and the disconnected one
just automatically obtained
by [? exponentiation. ?]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HONG LIU: Sorry?
No, no.
Here the metric matters,
the geometry matters.
It's not just the topology.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Feynman diagram [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Yeah, just the key is that
the propagator of the Feynman
diagram essentially
[? encodes ?] the geometries.
And in encoding a
very indirect way.
Yeah.
Just read this part.
This section only
have a few pages,
but contain a little bit more
details on what I have here.
It requires maybe one more hour
to explain this in more detail.
Yeah, this is just that.
I just want to explain
this philosophy.
I don't want to go through the
details of how you do this.
OK, good.
So now let me just mention
a couple of generalizations.
So the first thing
you already asked
before, I think maybe
both you have asked.
Let me just mention
them quickly.
And if you are interested,
I can certainly
give you a reference for
you to read about them,
or I can put it in
[? your P ?] sets.
And so, so far, it's all
matrix-valued fields, OK?
But if you can see the
theory-- or in other words,
in the mathematical
language, say,
it's an adjoint representation.
It's an adjoint
representation of the--
because our symmetries are
UN, it's a UN gauge group.
OK?
UN gauge group.
But you can also, for example,
in QCD, you also have quarks.
So you also have field in the
fundamental representations.
So it can also include field in
the fundamental representation.
So rather than matrix-valued,
they're N vector.
OK, they're N [? vectors. ?]
So for quarks, of course, for
the standard QCD N will be 3,
so you have three quarks.
You have three different
colored quarks.
And so then your
Feynman diagrams,
in addition to have
those matrix [? lines, ?]
which you have a double line.
And now here you only
have a single index, OK?
And then you only
have a single line.
So the propagator
of those quarks
will just have a single line.
And then also in
your Feynman diagram
you can have loops over
the quarks, et cetera.
So you can again work this out.
And then you find it is a
very nice large N expansion.
And then you find the
diagrams, the Feynman diagrams.
Now you find in this
case the Feynman
diagrams can be classified by
2D surfaces with boundaries.
So essentially, you have-- and
let me just say, for example,
this is the vacuum diagrams,
for all the vacuum process.
Then you can [INAUDIBLE]
or the vacuum diagrams.
And then they can all
be [? collectified. ?]
So previously, we have
a matrix-valued field.
Then all your vacuum
diagrams, they
are corresponding closed
surfaces-- so sphere,
torus, et cetera.
But now if you
include the quarks,
then those surfaces
can have boundaries.
And then [INAUDIBLE] into
the quark groups, et cetera.
And then they [? cannot ?]
be classified.
And so these also
have a counterpart
if you try to map to
the string theory.
So this [INAUDIBLE]
[? one and ?] [? two, ?] string
theory.
There's string theory with
both closed and open strings.
And so essentially
those boundaries
give rise to the open strings.
So here, it's all
closed strings.
It's all closed surface.
Well, now you can, by
adding the open strings,
and then you can, again,
have the correspondence
between the two.
OK.
So all the discussion
is very similar to what
we discussed before.
We just apply all this the
same philosophy to the quarks.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] do the
same trick on string theory
and find some sort
of expression which
then will map to some higher
order surfaces, [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: Sorry, say that again?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Feynman diagrams
we move to string
theory for surfaces.
Is there some [INAUDIBLE]
from surfaces just they go
one more [? step up? ?]
HONG LIU: You mean higher
dimensions, not strings.
Yeah, that will
become-- of course,
that's a [? lateral ?] idea.
So that will [INAUDIBLE] you can
consider [? rather ?] strings,
you can consider
two-dimensional surface,
a two-dimensional surface
moving in spacetime.
And then [INAUDIBLE] into
[? so-called ?] the membrane
theory.
But let's say where it
turns out to be-- turns out
string is a nice balance.
It's not too complicated
or not too simple.
And it give you
lots of structure.
But when you go to
membrane, then the story
become too complicated,
and nobody knows
how to quantize that theory.
So the second remark is
that here we consider UN.
So here our symmetry
group is UN.
Because our phi-- phi there is
[? commission. ?] So when you
have a [? commission ?] matrix,
then there's a difference
between the two indices, so
we put one up and one down.
So they are
propagators that lead
to-- so it leads to
the lines with arrows,
because we need to distinguish
upper and lower indices.
OK?
Between the two indices.
But you can also
consider, for example,
phi is a symmetric matrix.
Say it's a real
symmetric matrix.
It's a real symmetric,
or real anti-symmetric.
In those cases, then
there's no difference
between the two indices.
And then when you draw a
propagator-- so in this case
the symmetry group
would be, say,
SON, say, or SPN, et cetera.
And then the propagators,
they will no longer
have orientations.
OK?
They will no longer
have orientations.
Because you can
no longer-- yeah.
So this will give rise--
so let me write it closer.
So this will give rise
to unorientable surfaces.
Say, for example, to
classify the diagrams,
you can no longer just use
the orientable surfaces.
You also have to include
the non-orientable surfaces
to classify the diagrams.
And the [INAUDIBLE] this also
have a precise counterpart
into unorientable strings.
No, non-orientable strings.
Yeah, I think non-orientable,
non-orientable surfaces.
Also non-orientable strings.
Good.
So I'm emphasizing
how difficult it
is if, say, we want
to start with QCD
and then try to find the
string theory description.
But this still, [? none of ?]
this tries-- I just try.
OK, so let's just consider,
just take large N generalization
of QCD.
So this, again, will be
some UN gauge theory,
UN Yang-Mills theory, say, in
3 plus 1 dimensional Minkowski
spacetime.
And can we say anything about
its string theory description?
So [INAUDIBLE].
So maybe it's difficult,
but let's try to guess it.
OK.
So in physics, in
many situations,
a seemingly difficult problem,
if you know how to guess it,
actually you can get the answer.
On, for example,
quantum hole effects,
fractional quantum hole
effects, you can just
guess the wave function.
So of course, the
simplest guess--
so this is some gauge theory in
3 plus 1 dimensional Minkowski
spacetime.
So now we say this
is a string theory.
So natural guess
is that this maybe
is a string theory,
again, in the 3 plus 1
dimensional Minkowski spacetime.
OK?
So we just take what--
so these will, of course,
run into a string, propagating
in this spacetime, OK?
As I said, when you write
down the string theory,
you first have to specify
your target space, which,
as the string moves, the
larger question would be just,
should it be the gauge
theory's Minkowski spacetime.
Maybe this string
theory should be.
OK?
And then this.
Then you can just try
to-- then you can just
write down the simplest action.
So maybe say Nambu-Goto action,
which we wrote last time, OK?
Or the [? old ?]
Polyakov action.
So this Nambu-Goto action will
result [INAUDIBLE] Polyakov.
And let me not worry about that.
For example, you can
just guess, say, maybe
this is a string theory also
in the Minkowski spacetime.
Say, consider the
simplest action.
Or the equivalent of this, OK?
Then at least what
you could try-- now
you actually have an action.
Now you think that
you have this object.
Now you think you can compare.
OK, now you can
essentially compare.
Say, in QCD you calculated
your Feynman diagrams,
and now just compare.
But of course, you still
have the difficulty.
Of course, you have to
go to strong coupling
to see the geometric
limit, et cetera.
But in principle, it's
something you can do.
But this actually does not work.
OK?
This does not work, for the
following simple reason.
Firstly, that such
a string theory--
so a string theory, actually
the remarkable thing
about the string is that
if you have a particle,
you can put the particle
in any spacetime.
But strings are very picky.
You cannot put them
in any spacetime.
And they can only
propagate consistently,
quantum mechanically
consistently, in some spacetime
but not in others.
So for example, if you
want to put the string
to propagate in this 3 plus
1 dimensional Minkowski
spacetime, then you actually
find that the theory
is mathematically inconsistent.
So such a string
theory is inconsistent.
It's mathematically
inconsistent.
Except for the D
equal to 26 or 10.
OK?
So 26 if you just purely
have the theory, and 10
if you also add some fermion.
So such a string theory does
not exist mathematically.
So you say, oh, OK.
You say, I'm a smart fellow.
I can go around this.
Because we want the
Minkowski spacetime.
Because those gauge theory
propagating the Minkowski
spacetime, so this Minkowski
[INAUDIBLE] must be somewhere.
They cannot go away, because
all these glueballs [INAUDIBLE]
in this 3 plus 1 dimensional
Minkowski spacetime.
And if we want to identify the
strings with those glueballs,
those strings must at
least [? know ?] some
of this Minkowski spacetime.
And then you say, oh,
suppose you tell me
that this string theory is only
consistent in 10 dimension.
But then let me take a string
theory in 10 dimensions, which
itself consistent.
But I take this 10-dimensional
spacetime to have
the form of a 3
plus 1 dimensional
Minkowski spacetime.
And the [? time, ?] some
compact manifold, OK?
Some compact manifold.
And in such case-- so if
this is a compact manifold,
then the symmetry
of this spacetime,
so the spacetime
symmetry still only have
the 3 plus 1 dimensional,
[? say, ?] Poincare symmetry.
Because if you want to describe
the QCD in 3 plus 1 dimension,
QCD has the Poincare symmetry.
You can do Lorentz
transformation,
and then you can do rotation.
Or you can do translation.
The string theory should not
have more symmetries or less
symmetries than QCD.
They should have
the same symmetries
because they are supposed
to be the same description.
But if you take the
10-dimensional Minkowski space,
of course, it's not right.
Because the
10-dimensional Minkowski
space have 10-dimensional
translation
and 10-dimensional
Lorentz symmetry.
But what you can do is that you
take this 10-dimensional space
to be a form of the 3 plus
1 dimensional Minkowski
spacetime and times some
additional compact manifold,
and then you have solved
the symmetry problem.
But except this
still does not work
because the string theory, as
we know, always contain gravity.
And if you put a string theory
on such a compact space N,
[? there would be ?]
always leads
to a massless spin-2 particle in
this 3 plus 1 dimensional part.
But from Weinberg-Witten theorem
we talked in the first lecture,
in the QCD you are
not supposed to have
a 3 plus 1 dimensional
massless spin-2 particle, OK?
And so this won't work.
So this won't work.
Because this contains--
In 3 plus 1 dimensional
[? Minkowski space, ?]
which does not have-- OK?
Or in the large N [INAUDIBLE].
So this does not work.
So what to do?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So does this just
mean that it's mathematically
inconsistent?
HONG LIU: No, no.
This does not mean it is
mathematically inconsistent.
It just means this string
theory cannot not correspond
to the string theory
[? describe ?] QCD.
The string theory description--
the equivalent string theory
for QCD cannot
have this feature.
Yeah, just say this cannot
be the right answer for that
string theory.
This string theory
is consistent.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So is
that you were saying
if there is a massless spin-2
particle in that string theory,
there has to be a
[? counterpart in the ?] QCD.
HONG LIU: That's right.
AUDIENCE: If there is not a
[INAUDIBLE], that won't work
HONG LIU: Yeah.
This cannot be a
description of that.
From Weinberg-Witten theorem,
we know in QCD there's
no massless spin-2 particle.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I thought we have
talked about maybe we can do
strings to [? find ?] QCD in
a different dimension [? in ?]
space.
HONG LIU: We will go into that.
But now they are in
the same dimension,
because this
Minkowski 4, this will
have-- because this is a compact
[? part, ?] it doesn't matter.
So in this part, [? there are ?]
massless spin-2 particles.
This does not
[? apply ?] in QCD.
So what can you do?
So most people just give up.
Most people give up.
So other than give up,
the option is say maybe
this action is too simple.
Maybe you have to look
at more exotic action.
OK.
So this is one possibility.
And the second possibility
is that maybe you
need to look for some
other target space.
OK.
But now, what if you
go away from here?
Once you go away from
here, everything else
is now becoming such
little in the ocean,
because then you don't
have much clue what to do.
We just say, your basic
guess just could not work.
So for many years, even though
this is a very intriguing idea,
people could not make progress.
But now we have hindsight.
So we know that even this
maybe cannot be described
by a four-dimensional-- so
even though this cannot have
a-- so this cannot have a
massless spin-2 particle
in this 3 plus 1 dimension
of Minkowski spacetime.
Maybe you can still have
some kind of graviton
in some kind of a
five-dimensional spacetime.
You have some five dimensions,
in a different dimension.
So there were some rough hints.
Maybe you can consider there's a
five-dimensional string theory.
So let me emphasize when
we say five or four,
I always mention the
non-compact part.
So the compact part, it doesn't
count because compact part just
goes for the ride.
What determines the
properties, say,
of a massless
particle, et cetera,
is the uncompact
of the spacetime.
Yeah, because this is a
10-dimensional spacetime.
This is already not [INAUDIBLE].
So maybe we [? change ?]
for string theory
in five-dimensional uncompact.
AUDIENCE: Five, so in 4 plus 1?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
In 4 plus 1 uncompact spacetime.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
compactors.
When you say
compact, do you mean
the mathematical
definition of compactness?
HONG LIU: Yeah, that's right.
Yeah, I just say there
is a finite volume.
Just for our purpose
here, we can do it simply.
Just let's imagine--
yeah, compact always
has a finite
volume, for example.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why can we just
ignore the compact dimensions?
Is there any condition on
how big they're allowed
to be or something, like limit?
HONG LIU: Yeah, just
when you have-- so
if you know a little
bit about this thing
called the Kaluza-Klein theory.
And you know that the
compact part-- the thing
is that if you have
a theory [? based ?]
on uncompact and
the compact part,
and then most of the
physical properties
is controlled by the
physics of uncompact parts.
And this will
determine some details
like the detailed
spectrum, et cetera.
But the kind of
thing we worry about,
whether you have this massless
spin-2 particle, et cetera,
will not be determined
by this kind of thing.
AUDIENCE: Is there
any volume limit
on the compact
part, like maximum?
HONG LIU: No, it's fine
to have a finite volume.
AUDIENCE: Just finite,
but can it be large?
HONG LIU: No matter how
large, this have infinite.
It's always much
smaller than this one.
Yeah, but now it's
just always relative.
It's always relative.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Tracking
back a little,
is there any quick explanation
for 26 and 10 are special,
or is it very complicated?
HONG LIU: Um.
[LAUGHTER]
No, it's not complicated.
Actually, we were going
to do it in next lecture.
Yeah, next lecture we will
see 26, but maybe not 10.
10 is little bit
more complicated.
Most people voted
for my option one,
so that means you will
be able to see the 26.
Right.
AUDIENCE: Who
[? discovered ?] 26 and 10?
I mean, they are specific
for this [INAUDIBLE] action
rate, so for other action
would be something else.
HONG LIU: Specifically for
the Nambu-Goto action is 26.
And for the 10, you need to
add some additional fermions
and make it into a so-called
superstring, then become 10.
And even this 26 one is not
completely self-consistent.
And anyway, there's still
some little, tiny problems
with this.
Anyway, so normally we use 10.
OK so now, then there's
some tantalizing hints
for the-- say, maybe you
cannot do it with the 3 plus 1
dimensional uncompact spacetime.
Maybe you can do a 4 plus
1 dimensional uncompact.
So the first is the
holographic principle,
where you have length.
Holographic principle we have
learned because there we say,
if you want to describe
a theory with gravity,
then this gravity should
be able to be described
by something on its boundary.
And the string theory is
a theory with gravity.
So if the string
theory should be
equivalent to some kind of
QCD, some kind of gauge theory
without gravity, and then
from holographic principle,
this field theory maybe should
be one lower dimension, OK?
In one lower dimension.
Is the logic here clear?
AUDIENCE: Wait, can
you say that again?
HONG LIU: So here we
want to equate large N
QCD with some string theory.
But string theory we
know contains gravity.
A list of all our
experience contain gravity.
But if you believe that
the gravity should satisfy
holographic principle, then the
gravity should be equivalent,
according to
holographic principle,
gravity in, say, D
dimensional spacetime
can be described by
something on its boundary,
something one dimension lower.
AUDIENCE: But I thought
the holographic principle
was a statement about entropy.
HONG LIU: No, it's
a state started
from a statement about entropy.
But then you do a
little bit of leap.
So what I call it little
bit of a conceptual leap
is that the-- or
[? little ?] leap of faith
is that you promote that
into the statement that
said the number
of degrees freedom
you needed to describe
the whole system.
Yeah, so the
holographic principle
is that for any region, even
the quantum gravity theory,
for any region, you should
be able to describe it
by the degrees of freedom living
on the boundary of that region.
And degrees freedom living on
the boundary of that region,
then it's one dimensional lower.
AUDIENCE: Wait, so can I
ask one question about that?
If I have some region,
some volume in space,
some closed ball or something.
And I live in a universe which
is, for example, a closed--
like maybe they live
on some hypersphere
or something like this.
Then how do I know whether
I'm-- how do I know that
the information is encoded?
How do I know whether
I'm inside the sphere
or outside of the sphere?
For example, we see
that the entropy that
has to do with the
sphere basically
tells you about how
much information can you
contain inside the sphere.
But if you live in a universe
which is closed or something,
then you don't
know whether you're
inside or outside the sphere.
HONG LIU: Yeah, but that's
a difficult question.
Yeah, if you talk about
closed universe here,
we are not talking
about closed universe.
AUDIENCE: I see.
HONG LIU: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I thought the
holographic principle
is that the number of degrees
freedom inside the region
is actually bounded by the area.
HONG LIU: Right,
it's bounded by--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but
why is it that we
use that degree of freedom
living on the boundary?
HONG LIU: There are several
formulations of that.
First is that the total
number of degrees freedom
in this region is
bounded by the area.
And then you can go to the
next step, which is maybe
the whole region can
be just described
by these degrees
of freedom living
on the boundary on that region.
AUDIENCE: Is that because,
say, the state of density
on the boundary [INAUDIBLE]
the state on the boundary
is proportional to the
area of the boundary?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Exactly.
That's right.
AUDIENCE: So here our goal is to
recover the large N theory in 3
plus 1 dimensions
without gravity.
So we have no gravity.
You can't 3 plus 1.
HONG LIU: Right.
Yeah, so if that is supposed
to be equivalent to the gravity
theory, and the
gravity [? theory ?]
to find the
holographic principle,
and then the natural
guess is that
this non-gravitational
field theory should
live in one dimensional lower.
OK?
So this is one hint.
And the second is actually
from the consistency
of string theory itself.
So this is a little
bit technical.
Again, we will only
be able to explain it
a little bit later, when we talk
about more details about string
theory.
You can [? tell, ?] even though
the string theory in this space
is inconsistent.
But there's a simple way.
This is-- it's not a simple way.
So what's happening
is the following.
So if you consider,
say, a string
propagating in this spacetime,
and there are some symmetries
on the worldsheet.
And only in the 10
and 26 dimension,
those symmetries are satisfied
quantum mechanically.
And in other dimensions,
those symmetries, somehow,
even though
classically it's there,
but quantum
mechanically it's gone.
And those symmetries
become-- because they
are gone quantum
mechanically, then
it leads to inconsistencies.
And it turns out that
there's some other way
you can make that consistent,
to make that symmetry still
to be valid, is by adding
some new degrees of freedom.
OK?
It's just there's
some new degrees
freedom dynamically generated.
And then that new
degrees freedom
turned out to behave like
an additional dimension.
OK.
Yeah, this will make
no sense to you.
I'm just saying a consistency
of string theory actually
sometimes can give you
one additional dimension.
AUDIENCE: What is the difference
between these inconsistencies,
talking about anomalies and--
HONG LIU: It is anomalies.
But here it's called
gauge anomalies.
It's gauge anomalies is at
the local symmetry anomalies,
which is inconsistent.
AUDIENCE: So just--
maybe this is not
the time to ask this-- but
are the degrees of freedom
that you need to save you from
this inconsistency problem.
So do they have to be
extra dimensions of space?
Or what I'm saying is that if we
need to do string theory in 10
dimensions, is it really
four dimensions plus six
degrees of freedom?
Or are they actually six
bona fide spatial dimensions?
HONG LIU: Oh, this is
a very good question.
So if you have--
yeah, this something
we would be a little bit more
clear just even in-- oh, it's
very late.
Even the second
part of this lecture
is that here you have
four degrees of freedom,
you have six degrees of freedom.
But turns out, if you
only consider this guy,
then this four degrees freedom
by itself is not consistent.
It's [? its own ?] violation
of the symmetry at the quantum
level.
And then you need to add
more, and then one more,
because of course one and
two have extra dimension.
Anyway, we can make it more
explicit in next lecture.
Here I just throw a remark here.
Anyway, this guy-- this
is purely hindsight.
Nobody have realized this
point, this first point,
nobody have realized it before
this holographic duality
was discovered.
Nobody really made
this connection.
And at this point,
saying there should
be a five-dimensional
string theory
describing gauge theory,
that was made just
before the discovery.
I will mention that
a little bit later.
Anyway, so now let's-- let
me just maybe finish this,
and we have a break.
So now let's consider--
suppose there is
a five-dimensional
spacetime, string theory
in some five-dimensional
spacetime,
say 4 plus 1 dimensional
spacetime that describes QCD.
Then what should be
the property of this Y?
So this Y denotes
some manifold Y. OK?
So as I mentioned, it must have
at least all the symmetries
of the QCD, but not more.
Should have exactly the
same amount of symmetries.
So that means it must have
the translation and Lorentz
symmetries of QCD.
OK?
So that means the only
metric I can write down
must be of this form.
The only metric
I can write down,
the metric must
be have this form.
So this az just some function.
And z is the extra dimension
to a Minkowski spacetime.
And this is some Minkowski
metric for 3 plus 1 dimension.
AUDIENCE: You mean it's like
a prototype to four dimension,
we have to get the
Minkowski space.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Just say whatever
this space, whatever
is the symmetry of this-- so
the symmetry of this spacetime
must have the
Poincare-- must have
all the symmetry of the
3 plus 1 dimensional
Minkowski spacetime.
Then the simplest way, you're
saying that the only way
to do it is just you put the
Minkowski spacetime there
as a subspace.
And then you have
one additional space,
and then you can have
one additional dimension.
And then, because
you have to maintain
the symmetries and [INAUDIBLE]
to be thinking then
you can convince yourself that
the only additional degrees
freedom in the
metric [INAUDIBLE]
is the overall function.
So the function of this
z, and nothing else.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Can that
be part of kind
of a scalar in Minkowski space?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Let me just say,
this is most general
metric, consistent with
four dimensional, 3 plus 1
dimensional,
Poincare symmetries.
AUDIENCE: Why this additional
dimension always in a space
part?
Can it be in a time-like part?
Like a 3 plus 2?
HONG LIU: Both arguments
suggest it's a space part.
So because this is just
the boundary of some region
there's a spatial dimension
[? reduction ?], not time.
So is this clear to you?
Because you won't have
a Minkowski spacetime,
so you must have
a Minkowski here.
And then in the prefactor
of the Minkowski,
you can multiply by
anything, any function,
but this function
cannot depend on the X.
It can only depend on
this extra dimension.
Because if you have anything
which depend on capital X,
then you have violated
the Poincare symmetry.
You have violated the
translation [? X. ?]
So the only function you can put
before this Minkowski spacetime
is a function of this
additional dimension.
And then by redefining
this additional dimension,
I can always put this
overall factor in the front.
Yeah, so this
tells you that this
is the most general metric.
OK?
So if it's not clear to you,
think about it a little bit
afterwards.
So these are the
most as you can do.
So that's the end.
So you say, you cannot
determine az, et cetera.
So this is as most you
can say for the QCD.
But if the theory, if the field
theory is scale invariant,
say, conformal field theory,
that normally we call CFT, OK?
So conformal field theory.
Then we can show this metric.
So let me call this equation 1.
Then 1 must be
[INAUDIBLE] spacetime.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
symmetry on the boundary
as well, [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: Yeah, I'm
going to show that.
So if the field theory
is scale invariant, that
means that the fields theory
have some additional symmetry,
should be satisfied
by this metric.
And then I will show that this
additional scaling symmetry
will make this to precisely
a so-called anti-de Sitter
spacetime.
AUDIENCE: Field theory,
and then the 3 plus 1.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Right.
If the field theory, say the--
QCD does not have a scale.
It's not scaling right, so
I do not say a QCD anymore.
Just say, suppose
some other field
theory, which have
large N expansion, which
is also scale invariant.
And then the corresponding
string theory
must be in anti-de
Sitter spacetime.
AUDIENCE: Are we ever
going to come back to QCD,
or is that a--
HONG LIU: No, that's it.
Maybe we'll come back to QCD,
but in a somewhat indirect way.
Yeah, not to your
real-life, beloved QCD.
AUDIENCE: So no one's
solved that problem still?
HONG LIU: Yeah, no one's
solved that problem yet.
So you still have a chance.
So that remains very simple.
So let me just say, then
we will have a break.
Then we will be done.
I think I'm going
very slowly today.
So scale invariant theory--
is invariant under the scaling
for any constant,
constant lambda.
So scale invariant
theory should be
invariant under such a scaling.
And then now we want to
require this metric also
have this scaling.
OK?
So now, we require 1
also have such scaling.
That's scaling symmetry.
OK, so we just do a scaling
X mu go to lambda X mu.
And then this term will give
me additional lambda squared.
So we see, in order for this
to be the same as before, the z
should scale the same, OK?
So in order for this to be-- so
we need z to scale as the same,
in order I can scale
this lambda out.
After I scale this
lambda out, I also
need that a lambda z should be
equal to 1 over lambda az, OK?
So the scaling symmetry
of that equation
requires these two conditions.
So on the scaling of
z, this a lambda z
should satisfy this condition.
Then the lambda will cancel.
So this condition is
important because we
did scale them homogeneously.
Otherwise, of course,
lambda will not drop out.
And the second condition just
makes sure lambda is canceled.
OK, is it clear?
So now this condition
just determined
that az must be a
simple power, must
be written as R divided by z.
See, R is some constant.
And now we can write
down the full metric.
So now I've determined
this function up
to our overall constant.
So the full metric is dS square
equal to R squared divided
by z squared dz squared plus
eta mu, mu, dX mu, dX mu.
And this is
precisely AdS metric,
written in certain coordinates.
And then this R, then you adjust
the curvature radius of AdS.
So if you don't know about
anti-de Sitter spacetime,
it doesn't matter.
So this is the metric, and
the name of this metric
is anti-de Sitter.
And later we will
explain the properties
of the anti-de Sitter spacetime.
So now we find, so now
we reach a conclusion,
is that if I have a
large N conformal field
theory in Minkowski
D-dimensional space, time.
So this can be applied
to any dimensional.
It's not necessary
[? to be ?] 3 plus 1.
In D-- so this, if it can be
described by a string theory,
should be string
theory in AdS d plus 1.
And in particular, the 1/N here
is related to the g strings
here, the string coupling here.
So this is what we concluded.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So all we've
shown is that there
is no obvious inconsistency
with that correspondence.
HONG LIU: What do you
mean there's no obvious?
AUDIENCE: As in, we didn't
illustrate any way that they--
HONG LIU: Sure, I'm just saying
this is a necessary condition.
AUDIENCE: Right, so at
least that is necessary.
HONG LIU: Yeah, this is
a necessary condition.
So if you can describe a large
N CFT by our string theory--
and it should be a
string theory-- yeah,
this proposal works.
This proposal passed
the minimal test.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
So when Maldacena presumably
actually did figure this out,
you said that this resulted
from the holographic principle,
like it was just figured
out right before he did it.
Was he aware of
the holographic--
HONG LIU: No, here is
what I'm going to talk.
So Maldacena, in 1997, Maldacena
found precisely-- in 1997,
Maldacena found a few examples
of this, precisely realized
this.
And not using this mass or using
some completely indirect way,
which we will explain next.
So he found this through
some very indirect way.
But in principle, one
could have realized this
if one kept those
things in mind.
So now let me tell you a
little bit of the history,
and then we will have a break.
Then we can go home.
It depends on whether
you want a break or not.
Maybe you don't want a break.
Yeah, let me tell you a
little bit of history.
So yeah, just to save time,
let me not write it down, just
say it.
So in the late '60s
to early '70s, so
string theory was developed to
understand strong interactions.
So understanding strong
interactions was the problem.
At the time, people were
developing string theory
to try to understand
strong interactions.
So in 1971, our friend
Frank, Frank Wilczek,
and other people, they discover
the asymptotic freedom.
And they established
the Yang-Mills theory
as a description of
strong interaction
which now have our QCD.
And so that's essentially
eliminated the hope of string
theory to describe QCD.
Because the QCD seems
to be very different.
You [? need ?] the
help of string theory
to describe strong
interaction because the QCD
[INAUDIBLE] gauge theory, it's
very different from the string
theory.
So people soon abandoned
the string theory.
So now we go to 1974.
So 1974, a big number of
things were discovered in 1974.
So 1974 was a golden year.
So first is 't Hooft realized
his large N expansion
and then realized
that this actually
looks like string theory.
And then completely
independently,
Scherk, Schwarz,
and [? Yoneya, ?]
they realized that
string theory should
considered a theory of
gravity, rather than
a theory of strong interaction.
So they realized
actually-- it's ironic,
people started doing string
theory in the '60s and '70s, et
cetera.
But only in 1974
people realized,
ah, string theory
always have a gravity
and should be considered
a theory of gravity.
Anyway, so in
1974, they realized
the string theory should
be considered as a gravity.
So that was a very, very
exciting realization,
because then you can have
[? quantum ?] gravity.
But by that time, people had
given up on string theory.
So nobody cared about this
important observation.
Nobody cared about this
So, also in the
same year, in 1974,
Hawking discovered
his Hawking radiation.
And they established that
black hole mechanics is really
a thermodynamics.
Then really established
that the black hole
is a thermodynamic object,
And in 1974 there's also a
lot of important discovery--
which is related
to MIT, so that's
why I'm mentioning it-- is that
people first really saw quarks
experimentally, is that, again,
our friend, colleague Samuel
Ting at Brookhaven,
which they discovered
a so-called charmonium, which
is a bounce state of the charm
quark and the anti-charm quark.
And because the charm
quark is very heavy,
so they form a
hydrogen-like structure.
So in some sense, the charmonium
is the first-- you first
directly see the quarks.
And actually, even after the
1971, after asymptotic freedom,
many people do not believe QCD.
They did not believe in quarks.
They say, if there's quarks,
why don't we see them?
And then in 1974, Samuel Ting
discovered this charmonium
in October.
And so people call it
the October Revolution.
[LAUGHTER]
Do you know why they laugh?
OK.
Anyway.
Yeah.
Yeah, because I
saw your emotions,
I think you have
very good composure.
Anyway, in the same
year, in 1974, Wilson
proposed what we now
call the lattice QCD,
so he put the QCD
on the lattice.
And then he
invented, and then he
developed a very
beautiful technique
to show from this putting
QCD on the lattice
that, actually, the quark can
be confined through the strings.
So the quarks in QCD can be
confined through the strings.
And that essentially
revived the idea maybe
the QCD can be a string
theory, because the quarks are
confined through the strings.
And this all happened in 1974.
So then I mentioned the
same, in the late '80s
and the early '90s,
people were looking
at these so-called
matrix models, the matrix
integrals, et cetera.
Then they showed they related
to lower dimensional string
theory.
But nobody-- yeah, they
showed this related
to some kind of lower
dimensional string theory.
And then in 1993 and
1994, then 't Hooft
had this crazy idea of
this holographic principle.
And he said maybe, things
about the quantum gravity
can be described by things
living on the boundary.
And again, it's a crazy idea.
Very few people paid
attention to it.
But the only person who picked
it up is Leonard Susskind.
And then he tried to come up
with some sort of experiments
to show that that
idea is not so crazy.
Actually, Susskind wrote a
very sexy name for his paper.
It's called "The
World As a Hologram."
And so that paper
received some attention,
but still, still, people did
not know what to make of it.
And then in 1995, Polchinski
discovers so-called D-branes.
And then we go to 1997.
So in 1997, first in
June, so as I said,
that QCD may be some
kind of string theory.
This idea is a
long idea, starting
from the 't Hooft and
large N expansion, and also
from the Wilson's picture
of confining strings
from the lattice QCD, etc.
But it's just a
very hard problem.
If from QCD, how can you
come up with a string theory?
It's just very hard.
Very few people
are working on it.
So in 1997, in June,
Polyakov finally, he
said, had a breakthrough.
He said that this
consistent [? of ?]
string theory give you
one extra dimension,
you should consider a
five-dimensional string
theory rather than a
four-dimensional string theory.
And then he gave up
some arguments, anyway.
And he almost always actually
write down this metric
And maybe he already wrote down
this metric, I don't remember.
Anyway, he was
very close to that.
But then in November,
then Maldacena
came up with this idea of CFT.
And then he provided
[? explicit ?]
examples of certain large
N gauge theories, which
is scale invariant
and some string
theory in certain
anti-de Sitter spacetime.
And as I said, through
the understanding
of these D-branes.
But even Maldacena's
paper, he did
not-- he was still thinking from
the picture of large N gauge
theory corresponding
to some string theory.
He did not make the connection
to the holographic principle.
He did not make a connection
But very soon, in February
1998, Witten wrote the paper,
and he made the connection.
He said, ah, this is precisely
the holographic principle.
And this example, he said,
ah, this example is precisely
the holographic
principle Susskind
and 't Hooft was talking about.
So that's a brief history
of how people actually
reached this point.
So the next stage,
what we are going to do
is to try to derive [INAUDIBLE].
So now we can-- as I
said, we have two options.
We can just start
from here, assuming
there is CFT [? that's ?]
equivalent to some string
theory.
And then we can see how we
can develop this further.
And this is one
option we can take.
And our other option
is to really see
how this relation actually
arises from string theory.
And many people voted
for the second option,
which in my [? email ?]
is option one.
So you want to see
how this is actually
deduced from string theory.
So now we will do that, OK?
But I should warn you, there
will be some technicality
you have to tolerate.
You wanted to see how
this is derived, OK?
So we do a lot of
[? 20 ?] minutes today?
Without break?
Good.
OK.
Yeah, next time, I
will remember to break.
OK.
So now we are going
to derive this.
So first just as
a preparation, I
need to tell you a little
bit more about string theory.
In particular, the
spectrum of closed strings,
closed and open strings.
And so this is
where the gravity--
and from a closed string
you will see the gravity,
and from the open string, you
will see the gauge theory.
OK.
We will see gravity
and gauge theory.
So these are the first
things we will do.
So the second thing we will do--
so the second thing we will do
is to understand the
physics of D-branes.
So D-brane is some
object in string theory.
And it turned out to play
a very, very special role,
to connect the gravity
and the string theory.
OK.
Connect the gravity
and the string theory.
Because this is the
connection between the gravity
and the string theory.
And in string theory,
this [? object will ?]
deeply and precisely
play this role,
which connects the gravity
and the string theory.
So that's why you can
deduce such a relation.
OK.
Yeah, so this is the
two things we will
do before we can derive this.
So this is, say,
the rough plan we
will do before we can
derive this gravity.
So first let's tell you a little
bit more about string theory.
So at beginning, just say
some more general setup
of string theory.
So let's consider a string
moving in a spacetime, which
I denote by M, say, with
the metric ds squared
equal to g mu mu.
And this can depend
on X, dX mu, dX mu.
OK?
So you can imagine some
general curved spacetime.
Say mu and nu will go
from 0 to 1, to D minus 1.
So D is the total number of
space dimensions for this M.
So the motion of the string, as
we said quite a few times now,
is the embedding of the
worldsheet to the spacetime.
So this is in the form
of X mu sigma tau.
OK, you parameterize the
worldsheet by two coordinates.
So I will also write
it as X mu sigma a.
And the sigma a is equal
to sigma 0, and the sigma
1 is equal to tau sigma, OK?
And we will use this notation.
So now imagine a surface
embedded in some spacetime.
And this is the
embedding equation.
Because if you know
those functions,
then you know precisely how
the surface are embedded, OK?
And because the original
spacetime have a metric,
then this induced metric
on the worldsheet.
And this induced metric is
very easy to write down.
You just plug in this
function into here.
And when you take
the derivative,
you only worry
that sigma and tau,
because then that means you're
restricted on the surface,
when your only
[? value is ?] sigma and tau.
And then you can
plug this into there.
So you can get the metric, then
can be written in this form.
Here's sigma a and this sigma b.
OK?
So remember, sigma a and
sigma b just tau and sigma.
And this hab is just equal to
g mu mu, X, partial a, X mu,
partial b, X nu.
OK?
So this is trivial to see.
Just plug this into there,
to the variation with sigma
and tau, you just get
that, and it's that.
OK?
Is it clear?
So this Nambu-Goto action
is the tension-- tension
we always write this 1
over 2 pi alpha prime-- dA.
So alpha prime is the
[INAUDIBLE] dimensions square.
So we often also write
alpha prime as ls square.
So alpha prime, just
a parameter, too.
Parameterize to [? load ?]
the tension of the string.
So this area, of
course, you can just
write it as d squared sigma.
So again, you use the
notation d squared sigma
just d sigma d tau.
d squared sigma minus delta h.
OK.
So this is just the
area, because this
is the induced metric
on the worldsheet.
Then you take the determinant,
and that give you the area.
So this is the standard
geometric formula.
So now let me call
this equation 1.
So I have a [? lot ?]
equation 1 before,
but this is a new chapter.
OK.
So this is the explicit form
of this Nambu-Goto action.
But this action is a
little bit awkward,
because involving
the square root.
A square root, it's
considered to be
not a good thing in physics.
Because when you
write down action,
because it's a non-polynomial.
We typically like
polynomial things.
Because the only integral we
can do is a Gaussian integral,
and the Gaussian is polynomial.
So this is inconvenient, so one
can rewrite it a little bit.
So you write down the answer.
So we can rewrite it
in the polynomial form.
And this polynomial
form is corresponding--
it's called the Polyakov
action, so I call it SP,
even though Polyakov had
nothing to do with it.
And this action can be
written in the following form.
And let me write
down the answer.
Then I will show the equivalent.
AUDIENCE: Wasn't it invented
by Leonard Susskind?
HONG LIU: No, it's
not Leonard Susskind.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Why is it
called Polyakov--
HONG LIU: Polyakov--
yeah, actually Polyakov
had something to do with it.
Polyakov used it mostly
[INAUDIBLE] first.
OK, so you can rewrite
it as that, in this form.
And the gamma ab is a
new variable introduced.
It's a Lagrangian multiplier.
OK.
So let me point
out a few things.
So this structure is
precisely just this hab.
So that's if you look
at this structure,
so this structure is
precisely what I called hab.
So now the claim is
adding [INAUDIBLE]
to original variable
with just X. Now
I introduce a new
variable, gamma.
And gamma is like a
Lagrangian multiplier,
because there's no
connected term for gamma.
So if I eliminate gamma,
then I will recover this.
OK, so this is the claim.
So now let me show that.
This is very easy to see.
Because if you just do
the variation of gamma,
do the variation of gamma ab.
OK.
So whenever I wrote in
this is in [? upstairs, ?]
it always means the inverse.
OK, this is the standard
notation for the metric.
So if you look at the equation
of motion, [INAUDIBLE]
by variation of this gamma
ab, then what you'll find
is that the gamma ab-- just do
the variation of that action.
You find the equation
of motion for gamma ab
is given by the following.
So hab, just that guy.
And the lambda is arbitrary
constant, or lambda
is arbitrary function.
So this I'm sure you can do.
You just do the variation.
You find that equation.
So now we can just verify
this actually works.
When you substitute this
into here, OK, into here.
So this gamma ab, when you take
the inverse, then [? cause ?]
one into the inverse, hab,
inverse hab contracted
with this hab just give you 2.
And that 2-- did I put
that 2 in the right place?
That gave you 2.
And that have a 2 on-- yeah,
I'm confused about 2 now.
Oh, no, no, it's fine.
Anyway, so this
contracted with that,
so gamma ab contracted with hab
give you 2 divided by lambda,
times 2.
OK?
Because you just invert this
guy and invert the lambda and 2.
And then square root of
minus gamma give me 1/2
lambda, square root minus h.
OK?
So sometimes I also approximate.
I will not write this
determinant explicitly.
When I write [? less h, ?] it
means the determinant of h.
And the minus gamma,
determinant of gamma.
OK?
So you multiply these two
together, so these two cancel.
And this two, multiply
this 4 pi alpha prime,
and then get back that, OK?
So they're equivalent.
Clear?
So this gives you [? SNG. ?]
So now the key-- so now
if you look at this form,
this really have a
polynomial form for X, OK?
So now let me call
this equation 2.
So equation 2, if you
look at that expression,
just has the form--
so this is just
like a two-dimensional
field theory-- has
the form of a
two-dimensional scalar field
theory in the curved spacetime.
Of course, the curved spacetime
is just our worldsheet sigma
with metric gamma ab, OK?
So this is just like--
but the key here,
so sometimes 2 is called the
nonlinear sigma model, just
traditionally, a
theory of the form
that equation 2 is called
the nonlinear sigma model.
Nonlinear because typically
this metric can depend on X,
and so dependence
on X is nonlinear.
So it's called
nonlinear sigma model.
But I would say it's both
gamma ab and X are dynamical.
Are dynamical variables.
So that means when you
do the path integral,
so in the path
integral quantization,
you need to integrate
over all possible gamma
ab and all possible X mu.
Not only integrate
over all possible X mu,
but also integrate all possible
gamma ab with this action.
OK.
So this is a
two-dimensional [? world ?]
with some scalar field.
And you integrate over
all possible metric,
so over all possible intrinsic
metric in that [? world. ?]
So this can also be
considered as 2D gravity,
two-dimensional gravity,
coupled to D scalar fields.
So now we see that when
you rewrite anything
in this polynomial form,
in this Polyakov form,
the problem of
quantizing the string
become the problem of quantizing
two-dimensional gravity coupled
to D scalar fields.
OK.
So this may look very scary,
but it turns out actually
two-dimensional
gravity is very simple.
So it's actually not scary.
So in the end, for
many situations,
this just reduced to,
say, a quantizing scalar
field with a little
bit of subtleties.
So yeah, let's stop here.